unlock the next configuration 35 years
later we get a reimagination of Clive
Barker's classic Hellraiser with dozens
of hours in the makeup chair blinding
Prosthetics and an absurd amount of gel
blood this cast and crew went through
their own version of a horror movie
Behind the Scenes oh it's wild number
one Jamie Clayton has a full work day in
the makeup chair the makeup takes four
hours to do and about 45 minutes to an
hour to remove it's mostly applying a
ton of Prosthetics to her face and body
as well as stuffing her into an
extremely heavy tight and constricting
Pinhead suit if you didn't know she was
the one behind the mask she would be
completely unrecognizable but it's so
number two cenobites rarely show Mercy
Jamie Clayton and IFA Hines developed a
close friendship on the set of the film
so having to play out a scene where
Pinhead brutalizes ifa's character was
particularly hard for Jaime to get
through it was very hard for me because
I was like oh I really like her like why
am I doing this it was like that with
all of her castmates as she had great
camaraderie with all of them but I
became very close with FIFA and with
Brandon and yeah so it was it was tough
we're hoping for an extensive release of
deleted scenes and bloopers with all of
pinhead's apologies after the cut number
three Jaime really went through it not
only had she never worn Prosthetics
before but she literally couldn't see
anything most of the time while she was
filming because of the black contacts in
her eyes and she's like I can't see
anything guys please help me walk also
because the prosthetic suit was so
restrictive she really couldn't walk
that well you'll notice Pinhead stays in
one place Place most of the time and it
was really really hot and you have to
worry about the Santa bites like in
their costumes that they don't die from
heat exhaustion number four a lot of
different pins were experimented with in
the original movie they used plastic
tubes on the Pinhead prosthetic and
placed the pins inside also known as
styrene rods they ended up doing
something similar in the new movie but
they couldn't figure out a way to get
the pins to be stable and not move
during the performance it was a long and
grueling process the pearls you see on
the tip of the pins were hand drilled so
they could fit on the pins the
pearl-headed pins are a design element
that span all of the cinebike characters
a member of the crew said after they
wrapped he never wanted to look at
another pin for the rest of his life
number 5. messy and hard to remove in
the original design of the cenobites all
of them had exposed muscle tissue but
one day the director David Bruckner
decided he wanted it to look wet so they
decided to try out some gel blood it
looked really great so unfortunately
that became the thing they had to
reapply it before every scene the ads
would be screaming all right they're on
in 10 minutes blood them up they had to
wash the gel substance off every night
and it made the suits so incredibly
sticky it was a difficult process number
six the hooks are practical but the
chains are not there was some practical
prosthetic work to complete the illusion
that chains were coming out of the
actors bodies and they had built
Prosthetics around my my nipples that
the chains would go into they would then
shoot a bunch of different scenes of the
actors screaming and being pulled
forward so the chains could be added in
post I'm here the poles here it's
wrapped around my body and around the
pole off camera there would be a group
of guys pulling the actor forward so it
looked forceful versus if they were just
being pushed forward on their own
number seven also known as the cage
created to capture the cenobites the
exterior of the Mansion is an actual
building in Serbia but the mesh of metal
that kept the cenobites trapped inside
and out was created digitally the entire
interior of the Mansion was built on a
Sound Stage by the production design
team none of the expensive Interiors or
pristine Marvel were actually as
expensive as you'd think it was all wood
you know that looks like marble and
stuff like that so it was they did a
really good job number eight Jaime
scared everyone on set with her Stellar
performance not only did she portray a
stunning version of Pinhead while the
camera was rolling but even while they
were off the cast and crew were a little
afraid to approach her David Bruckner
even found himself a little creeped out
every now and then I have a wonderful
picture of her staying in character
while we were setting a shot up just in
The Labyrinth she was just standing
there with her hand on the wall
completely unrecognizable as Jaime
everyone was walking on eggshells
setting up that shot
probably my eeriest moment on sets
number nine the cenobites weren't the
only scare Factor on set these wild
foxes were like basically trying to eat
them because they just like look like
big pieces of meat that's right these
wild foxes were actually trying to eat
the actors in their cenobite costumes
it's hilarious seeing them switch from
like being so still to just like
freaking out those wild Serbian foxes
are definitely not ones to be messed
with number 10. animals seem to be the
theme with this cast while filming the
movie a couple of stray cats wandered
onto set and the cast ended up keeping
them and taking care of them in their
trailers
Marianne ended up being Brandon Flynn's
onset companion while Odessa a Zion
found a cat of her own you had another
cat Odessa you had dos Virginia number
11. it wouldn't have been so bad if the
power didn't go out there's a scene in
the film where Riley turns around to
tell Trevor to open open the gate so
when Odessa turns around Drew starkly is
right by the camera so her eye line is
in the correct place and she's like
to look at me and her lines do it and I
was like just right at the camera like
naturally Odessa ends up laughing and
ruining the take and then as soon as she
laughed the generators went out in the
building they ended up having to
postpone the shot yeah that's all that
we got and I got in trouble for it
because they were like Odessa why did
you laugh number 12. the cenobite
struggled with the cold Serbian weather
at night Selena Lowe in particular
didn't have much besides a thin layer of
silicone to cover up her legs a moment
of Comedy that came out of this was
because of her character's skin flaps
she was jumping up and down in her
little skin flap I like I wasn't paying
just trying to keep warm for sure you
know where this is heading when I see
her I look over and I hear this cute
little like clapping
it was apparently either too hot or too
cold there was never a comfortable day
for anyone number 13. the design of the
box was an integral part of the movie
David Bruckner brought in Martin amborg
a game Des designer and concept artist
at IO interactive known for his work on
the Hitman franchise and the sci-fi
horror game Echo what sets this puzzle
box apart from the 1987 design is that
it's able to transform into different
forms all representative of The Human
Experience the form language of the Box
emerged out of a combination of the
motif of a labyrinth a garden and a
circular mechanism number 14. there were
quite a few callbacks to the original
film leave us a comment and let us know
which ones you noticed one in particular
is probably one of the most famous lines
in the film we have such sights to show
you as fans of the franchise already
know you really don't want to see any of
the sights the cenobites have to offer
we have such sights to show you number
15 the 1987 original movie is vastly
different than this new version original
director Clive Barker was extremely
supportive of the new Direction the cast
and crew won to take the film he's like
you have to do your own thing you can't
you can't try to imitate this beat for
beat even the reasoning behind casting a
woman as Pinhead was so they could take
away the burden off the audience of
comparing the two films and performances
I hope you know that my performance is
different enough and unique enough and
that people like it this new span on the
1987's Hellraiser brought the cenobites
to life with an astounding amount of
Prosthetics Jamie Clayton's Stellar
dedication and a brilliant new design of
the puzzle box what was your favorite
part of the movie
thank you